what up space fam goes in here for anime
up brought in today we're going to be
looking at 10 interesting facts about
him eco toga I have plenty of videos in
the MHA fact series so make sure to
check out that playlist if you want more
MHA facts I'll link that playlist at the
end of this video and in the description
if you want me to make more maj fact
videos make sure the united states have
smashed that like button to let me know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or else you
won't know when future videos come out
if you have a specific character you
want to see a FAQ video about make sure
let me know in the comments in regards
to manga spoilers there will be some in
this video but I'll try to keep them to
a minimum now without further ado let's
jump into it for fact number one let's
take a look at togas name what he course
she puts a lot of thought into the names
of his characters even names like Tatsu
Tatsu Tatsu Tatsu are expertly chosen by
this naming master togas lasting
contains the kanji tole meaning migrate
and gah meaning self while her first
name contains the kanji for he meaning
where or put on me meaning somebody and
cold meaning child her name clearly
hints at her quirks since she leaves
behind her usual physical form in order
to quote-unquote put on somebody else's
physical form she always speaks of
wanting to become other people she
admires which implies leaving the old
her behind the child within her name
points of her being naive although she's
willing to hurt and even kill people she
often behaves in a childlike manner
except hemoccult Olga gets super excited
and cheery about blood rather than
Barbie dolls
she's like Juliet if Julia wanted the
stab Romeo drink his blood and wear his
skin for fact number two let's take a
close look at her quirk her quirk is
called transform and it not surprisingly
lets her transform into other people
after consuming their blood the more
blood she consumes the longer she can
maintain that person's physical form she
sounds like them and she can even
recreate their clothing however the
clothing would appear over her own
clothing giving her true identity away
for this reason toga must take off her
own clothes before using her power she
can actually switch back and forth
between multiple people if she has
access to the blood of more than one
person another interesting ability that
toga has access to is the
to erase her presence by holding her
breath and clearing her mind if the
opponent averts their attention for an
instant she can supposedly vanish from
their view using this ability hemoccult
Olga's quirk has also undergone an
awakening in the manga now not only can
she look and sound like the person she's
transformed into she can now use their
quirks - so she's like a trickier and
crazier Natal Monomoy now for fact
number three let's take a closer look at
the equipment he Makoto guy uses toga
has one of the most interesting outfits
in the series she wears a schoolgirl
outfit which is directly contrasted to
the mask knives needles and blood
machine that she carries toga is great.i
using knives she can use them
effectively in close combat or throw
them at the enemy in other words she's
proficient in tanto jutsu which is the
use of a short knife or dagger in combat
there's a history in Japan a warrior
woman learning tanto jutsu toga is a
unique modern and pretty crazy nod to
this history she also has a blood
sucking machine that is attached to a
number of needles
she carries two large green tubes on her
back that store the blood and the tubes
connect to six cylinders with needles
that can be fired at opponents and
retracted she can also take a cylinder
in her hand in order to directly stab a
nearby opponent the machine is set up so
that starts sucking blood as soon as a
needle connects with an opponent the
blood can be stored for later use or
consumed immediately this machine is
extremely useful because it lets her
strategically save people's blood for
later and use them for espionage
purposes or combat purposes for fact
number four we are going to be taking a
look at Himiko Tolga statistics which
have significantly improved over time in
the first data book toga got one out of
five in power four out of five and speed
three out of five and technique a three
out of five and intelligence and they
one out of five in cooperativeness in
the newer ultra analysis data book
released in October 2009 teen toga
scored a 1 out of 6 in power a 4 out of
6 in speed and this is when we start
seeing the significant growth and set up
3 out of 5 she got 5 out of 6 and
technique she jumped from a C to an A+
along with her improved awakened quirk
she also seems to have gotten smarter
her intelligence used to be a three but
it jumped to a five out of six going
from a C to an A
actually instead of cooperativeness the
last category was the customized
category of unruly hair and toga got 5
out of 6 a K and a in that no surprise
there some people on Instagram at anime
out Pro were surprised that she didn't
get a perfect 6 out of 6 in unruly hair
but to be fair she does at least have
her hair in a bun and furthermore
perfect scores are actually rarer than
you might expect in the ultra analysis
data book even Deku our protagonist got
no perfect scores like toga he got a 5
in intelligence and technique which
shows just how skilled toga actually is
now so now that we know that both of
these characters are similarly smart and
talented let me know if you ship them in
the comments below for fact number 5
let's look at amico togas popularity I
really love how Shonen manga include
these popularity contests I feel like
every show or franchise should have
these regularly because they're so fun
in the case of my hero academia in the
second and third Japanese popularity
polls toga came in 19th place making her
the most popular league of villains
member after she got Aki the main
antagonist of the series in the fifth
and most recent Japanese popularity poll
released in December 2019 Kimiko toga
jumped all the way to ninth place she
was one spot behind Oracle and one spot
ahead of Momo she was voted the second
most popular girl in the series even
though she's a villain and that's truly
impressive now let's look at the English
popularity results and see how the West
views Tolga compared to Japan in the
second English popularity poll toga got
higher than she did in any Japanese poll
she was the most popular girl in the
series and got in third place overall
behind only yuzu ku and Baku go and
ahead up Todoroki so right off the bat
it seems that the West was more obsessed
with toga but surprisingly in the most
recent u.s. viz media poll toga didn't
even make it to the top ten let me know
how you would rank toga yourself for
fact number six let's take a look at the
initial sketch that the manga artist
Kohei horikoshi did have Himiko toga
these sketches are always fun because
they show us what the character might
have been like and how they evolved over
time there were a number of hairstyles
horikoshi experimented with including
having togas hair completely untied and
even in pigtails that would shoot out
from the sides of her head
the untied hair version probably would
have got me perfect six out of six and
unruly hair the pigtails version didn't
have unruly hair at all but hoody course
she ended up going with the messy bun
hairstyle which has become togas
signature look at one point toga was
supposed to have all sharp teeth like a
shark rather than just the two vampire
like fangs that she ended up with her
character's personality and even her
quirks stayed pretty consistent but of
course she knew that she would be a bad
guy who always looks like she's in love
and wants to become the person she
admires he knew that she would get
incredibly excited when she saw someone
bleeding and that she'd be a sadist with
distorted desires actually within these
initial sketches there was a clue about
Olga's quirks awakening right away
horikoshi planned for toga to be able to
use the quirks of the people she
transformed into it seemed like he
decided against this because she could
only transform physically into her
target for a while but this changed when
her quirky volved recently in the manga
fact number seven what of course she had
and continues to have a lot of
difficulty with him eco toga what
eCourse she has said that toga is the
hardest female character to illustrate
especially because of her unique eyes
and messy hair even from the beginning
he had a hard time deciding how she
should look and what her name would be
it wasn't until the last minute that he
decided to make her hair the way it is
however despite all of that difficulty
it was worth it because she ended up
being one of the most popular characters
in the series one of the most cost
played anime characters at cons and one
of the most complicated and interesting
characters in the story her personality
like her appearance is full of
contradictions fact number 8 hoody
course she designed Himiko toga to be a
yandere a young that is a figure that
pops up regularly in Japanese fiction
and it can be defined as a fictional
character who fits the archetype of
being genuinely romantic loving kind
aful sparing sweet and gentle but is at
the same time brutal psychotic or
deranged and behavior
the psychotic tendency can be both
sudden and ever-present often used for
both comedic and dramatic displays of
character and quote this figure of the
young that it captures the
contradictions I mentioned earlier and
these contradictions make it hard to
judge him equal to and black-and-white
terms she's definitely not a purely good
character but she's not portrayed as a
purely evil character either and that is
what makes her
fascinating when she does show kindness
to twice and other members of the league
of villains you can't help but recognize
her as a complex human being with the
potential to do good and bad for a fact
number nine let's look at some nods and
possible influences for helical toga The
Masque toga wears for her villain outfit
seems to be a nod to Bane's mask from
The Dark Knight Rises a Batman film that
came out in 2012 what a course she is a
huge fan of western works like Star Wars
and superhero movies and these works
regularly appear in one form or another
in my hero academia he is a known fan of
Batman and it is very likely that
besides looking cool togas mask is
another example of his love for western
superhero comics and movies x-men also
inspired him as you can see in the idea
of a superhero school and even in class
1 B student Dorota Ishida who is a non
blue clone of the Beast from x-men like
mystique from x-men Kimiko toga is a
complicated female villain who can take
the shape of other characters and also
habitat yellow eyes again though no blue
skin let me know if you see any other
possible nods or inspirations in the
character of hemoccult Olga
lastly fact number 10 is a lightning
round of random facts which I rename
depending on the character I'm
discussing in the particular video in
question in honor of Hema Kota we shall
double the yonder around the end of the
round will begin in three two one less
Jam togas birthday is August 7th making
her a dedicated Leo her yellow hair and
cat-like eyes complement her lion
horoscope nicely she was sixteen years
old when the story first began but she
was currently 17 years old in the manga
her height is 157 centimeters tall or 5
foot 2 inches she is the youngest member
of the league of villains and she loves
blood and pomegranates a fruit that
symbolizes life and fertility but also
power blood and death and that is it for
today's fact video thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video make
sure to smash that like one to let me
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or else
you'll miss future MHA videos let me
know what videos and characters you
would like to see next in the comments
for more MHA content and important
updates on new seasons make sure to
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
Anime uproar a special thank you goes
out to our
patrons on patreon who help us survive
YouTube issues and who helped make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress fitted ala beat Anatole cos ASCII
alpha do angel Cruz and team Sparky 65
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Stephen and
Radha a lull on attempt Matty Mac 239
makoto-kun the world Steelers Tyson
Kirino and the school bus thank you all
so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
an Amir Pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to her
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
[Music]